hi rich hi adams my name is elizabeth
and i am in nanaimo british columbia
firstly i want to say how much i enjoy
your roll-on conversations
rich i also want to thank you for
providing a platform to educate and
challenge listeners to expand their
perspectives and their awareness
i credit you with encouraging me to
consider a plant-based lifestyle for
myself
and also through your guests and your
own perspective i've made that change
in my own life to great benefits i'm
really interested in getting your
perspectives
on leadership something i value and
treasure about your podcast and
perspective
is your self-awareness and your
willingness to examine yourself in your
life
i'm curious what your perspective is on
leadership how do you show up to lead
your team
do you have any advice for spiritual
self-aware individuals
that value doing the work on themselves
on how to show up in a professional
setting
and or perhaps ideas on how to blend
self-awareness and personal growth with
leadership
and encourage your team to do the same
what a cool
question elizabeth um thank you for that
i don't know if anybody's ever really
asked me about leadership before it is
it's fascinating i will admit
that uh i haven't spent a lot of time
pondering leadership and and probably
less time
studying it over the years um but i have
started thinking about it
a little bit more and shouldering this
mantle more recently because
i now employ people which is something i
never thought would happen
so i guess i would i would launch into
this response by saying
i'm a reluctant leader i don't consider
myself
a thought leader or a leader of teams i
think of myself as a solopreneur
somebody who relishes quiet alone time
i'm fundamentally a writer and
disposition
and always kind of consider myself
suited to doing my own thing
and wanting to be left alone i mean
that's still my greatest desires just to
be
left alone right yes but i recognize
that
i've created this situation
that places me now in the context of
having to lead
much more than i would have ever wanted
or realized and
with the growth of the podcast like i
said i have people that i employ now i
am a subcontractor you don't employ me
you are you're not
yes you don't report to me
i'll w-9 you um
i am a boss though which is weird and i
admit it's a little bit uncomfortable
for me but it's forced me to kind of
wrestle with some
growth stuff uh because
what i say how i say it and and more
importantly like what i do how i comport
myself how i handle myself matters to
other people
in my immediate orbit and so
i have started kind of thinking about
these issues
in a more meaningful way recently i
won't say that i have
any kind of specific philosophy of
leadership
but i do have a few touchstones and and
many of those i have to
say i credit um
to my business partner greg anzalone
like i've learned so much
from this guy i just think he's an
exemplary
human being and leader greg is the ceo
of sideshow sideshow collectibles
that's really you know what he like he's
my business partner but really his
business is sideshow which makes
limited edition collectible figures from
pop culture like all the star wars stuff
and marvel stuff like these limited runs
of like beautiful
um you know the baby yoda is their
product
stuff like that and um greg is somebody
i've come to
to really deeply admire and and respect
as one of the most
effective and compassionate leaders that
i've ever met
and somebody who in so many ways mimics
the findings and the research of of adam
grant who's the guy in the podcast this
week a guy who studied leadership deeply
for
for many many years and and so some of
those touchstones are
and this is coming from greg it's about
the people
not the product that the employees
come before the widget right like the
organization is is set up not to make
widgets but to empower people's lives
with meaning and purpose
um i've learned that uh it's wise to
approach every situation with a giving
mindset it's not about what you
uh can get out of a situation but how
you can better support the people
beneath you
i've learned that it's about action and
behavior what you say
is important but that must be aligned
with your actions which obviously speak
louder than words
and if your actions are misaligned with
your words then
you faltered so i think that's been
super
helpful to me um i'm a perfectionist so
learning that
progress is better than perfection is a
lesson hard rot for myself
something that i'm getting used to
because
your perfectionism might help you create
something that will get you to a certain
level but if you want to create
large s in a sustainable way you have to
empower the people around you and those
people
have their own ways of doing things and
and
that's not always going to meet up with
how you would do things so holding on
too tightly to your ideas
i think becomes an inhibitor to growth
so learning how to let go
and empower other people i think is
super important
i think anticipating the needs of the
people that you work with
is really powerful like creating
solutions to problems before they arise
because you can see where things are are
headed before they even get there
one of the things i've seen greg do is
just surprise and delight the people
that
work underneath him and alongside him by
showing up in ways that
others in a position of leadership don't
because they're thinking about
themselves
and greg's always thinking about other
people and he'll just show up and do the
thing
that nobody would have ever expected and
sometimes they're
big gestures and sometimes they're
little gestures but
they're always very meaningful like greg
will
will um you know find housing for an
employee or do something that
like a ceo or a person in a position of
leadership just wouldn't
you know you wouldn't think that they
would be thinking about the people who
work beneath them
in such a meaningful way and that's been
you know really
kind of amazing to see him do that time
and time again and has impacted me
um i think in terms of leadership
thinking about how to play the long game
is super important um not over indexing
for short-term
profitability or productivity but rather
thinking broadly about creating and
establishing sustainable systems that
allow people to flourish and do their
best work
not in a highly pressurized environment
but giving them a little bit of
bandwidth
so that they can feel
secure in their expression i think is
huge
adam has this great quote adam grant
which is
the most meaningful way to succeed is to
help others succeed
and it seems simple but i think it's
powerful
to not perceive the world as some kind
of zero-sum
equation but to look at things from a
broader more spiritual perspective that
the universe is
infinitely abundant so with that
give freely of yourself and service to
others and not only does that come back
in your direction tenfold it engenders
amazing trust and loyalty
in the people that that you work with
see we're back to the taoist philosophy
i mean that's really the whole like the
middle way is the taoist philosophy is
um if if if the few have much
and the many have little that's totally
completely anti the way the like the the
the nature of the dao and the idea is to
uh is to have everyone sharing the
abundance and so
like the fact that that you're citing
that as a driving philosophy for your
business bodes
well for your business if countries
worked out that way like
you know in scandinavia countries who
have a expanded social
safety net and are able to um
you know yes the taxes might be higher
to have health care and public education
at a high level and x y and z
but if you actually look at everyone's
bank account everyone has more money
the rich and the lower lower working
class and the middle class there is no
lower class
and so if you look at it that way
everyone does better
when there's enough for everyone and the
way we have it in our mind is
well if i have to pay this it's less for
me
you know that person should get should
get more of themselves you know
right but that's just not how it works
you know if everyone did better
everyone would do better it's very
simple but unfortunately
you know we do have a leadership vac i
love this question because we have a
leadership vacuum in this world right
now there's not
a lot of effective leaders you can point
to that are getting the job done
on a on a global or national level
there's a few that we we sometimes
identify
but it's hard and i think the great
leadership everything's like the best
leaders it's all happening local in
people's homes and people's businesses
yeah and and uh and i think greg's
amazing it's it's been
so cool to meet him and learn from him
so
well said yeah 100 and just and and
having a moral compass yeah and having
your actions
aligned with that perspective right
like isn't that what leadership is it's
not it's not just
you know bending to whatever is in your
self-interest in the moment which seems
to be the hallmark of
current times but rather you know
uh heeding a greater call and being
willing to
sacrif sacrifice yourself first in the
interest of that and i think
when you demonstrate that as a leader
that's very powerful for the people that
are following you agreed well said
[Music]
you